نحن بصراحه من اول ما عرفنا بالحادثه من
يوم الاحد كنا على متابعه دائمه وحسيسه
ودقيقه مع كل الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه
الموضوع كان مدار اهتمام بالغ قوى الامن
الداخلي وشعوبه المعلومات كانت عم تقوم
بعمليه ترصد وتعقب كبيره جدا الامن العام
ساهم جدا بعمليه الترصد الجيش اللبناني
ومخابرات الجيش اللبناني طبعا كانوا عم
يقوموا بدور كتير كبير
المواطن السعودي كان خارج من مطعم
بقريب من من وسط بيروت
وهناك جرى تعقبه الى مكان معين يمكن لازم
نتحفظ نقول وين تحديدا ثم حصلت العمليه
كانت كان مرصود بواسطه سياره مسروقه ويمكن
كان في سياره ثانيه السياره جرت متابعتها
كما جرت متابعه حركه الهاتف وين موجود
الهاتف في عده اماكن حيث تنقل الهاتف بين
عده اماكن وانا البارحه صرحت عن الموضوع
ثم الجيش اللبناني قام بعمليه
بعمليات تفتيش وبحث في البقاع في البقاع
الشمالي تحديدا وحتى الحدود
الحمد لله بتنسيق كل الاجهزه الامنيه
تم الوصول الى النتيجه السعيده النتيجه
المرجوه وهو تحرير المواطن الشقيق المواطن
السعودي الشقيق نحن بهايدي المناسبه مناكد
للبنانيين من اكد للاخوه العرب مناكد
لتاعات السفير انه القوى الامنيه
والعسكريه اللبنانيه متماسكه وتعمل بتنسيق
تام وهيدا اللي انا اكدته لقائد الجيش
باتصال في مبارح لما اكدنا على عمل القوى
الامنيه والعسكريه معا على توحيد جهودها
وتكثيف جهودها للوصول الى النتيجه اللازمه
وتحقيق الامن والامان لكل اللبنانيين ولكل
المقيمين على الاراضي اللبنانيه ولا سيما
العرب والسعوديين
بمناسبه الحادث الذي حصل
هذه جريمه هذه جريمه كبيره الخطف بقوه
السلاح والخطف والتهديد والخطف لقاء فديه
وتعكير او تخريب او محاوله تخريب علاقه
اللبنان بدول صديقه مثل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذه جرائم كبيره اكيد القضاء
اللبناني المستقل في عداء مهامه
سينظر
لفداحه هذه الجريمه ولخطوره هذه الجريمه
نحن عنا اليوم تسعه موقوفين تسع موقوفين
موجودين لدى مخابرات الجيش
بنتيجه هذه العمليه وبسبابها نحن هون
بنؤكد انه الموضوع ما بيكون اله علاقه
بعلاقات لبنان بالسعوديه علاقات لبنان
بالسعوديه ثابته ومكرسه وما حدا بيقدر
يهددها او يهزها انا كنت سابقا من هذه
الدار ان علاقتنا بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
تنقطع ولن تنقطع في كل الظروف نحن اكدنا
من هذه الدار ان السعوديه لم تترك لبنان
ولن تترك لبنان اهتمام المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بلبنان وباللبنانيين وبالاجهزه
الامنيه والعسكريه ووقوفها ووقوفها دائما
الى جانب الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه ودعم
الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه كافه ما يؤدي
الى الى حسن اداء الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه الى تطورها تكنولوجيا وتطورها
لوجستيان هذا موضوع كتير مقدر كما وقوف
المملكه الى جانب كافه القطاعات في لبنان
نحن حبينا انه نكون موجودين هون تنكد
ثباتنا بمواجهه الجريمه ثباتنا بمواجهه
الفتنه ثباتنا بمواجهه من يحاول
احداث اي خلل او تخريب في العلاقات خصوصا
بعد الارتياح الذي حصل
بنتيجه التفاهمات الاقليميه او التفاهمات
العربيه او بنتيجه القمه القمه السعوديه
هذا موضوع مستمر السياحه لن تتاثر الاجهزه
الامنيه والعسكريه اللبنانيه بجهد المكثف
وبجهد السريع
للوصول الى هذه النتيجه وتحرير المواطن
السعودي بوقت قياسي انما دليل على جديه
الشعب اللبناني بمحبته لاخوانه العرب
ولاعشقاء السعوديين جديه الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه اللبنانيه بمحاربتها للجريمه
كما حاربت سابقا المخدرات وتهريب الكاب
تاكون وعصابات تهريب الكبتاجون مستمره
الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه اللبنانيه
بمكافحه كافه انواع الجريمه ونحن بنقول
لكل العرب ولكل السعوديين ولساعات السفير
انه لبنان بلدهم لبنان باذن الله امن
بهمه الوطنيين من ابنائه لبنان بهمه
اللبنانيين
الشرفاء لبنان بمهمه لبنانيين على
الاقوياء لبنان بهمه الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه اللبنانيه العربيه الشرعيه
القويه
انما هو بلد كل اشقاء كل الاشقاء العرب
وهو بلد السعوديين
السعودي في متابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات